habituellement fermé le lundi les
grilles du château de versailles ont
accueilli cinq mille collégiens des
yvelines et des hauts-de-seine pour une
journée spéciale une visite imaginé par
les deux présidents des départements qui
confirment leur forte collaboration
elle est très facile elle est très
fluide et
nous espérons bien que d'ici la fin de
l'année nos deux départements n'en
feront plus qu'un seul
les élèves de classes de 4e bénéficié
d'une visite ponctuée par un orchestre
et d'ateliers sur l'écocitoyenneté la
chambre de luis saez l'agente de la
reine les salons un engagement commun
pour l'égalité des chances 84 collège
des deux départements ont pu participer
l'égalité des chances ça veut dire que
chaque enfant de nos départements
quel que soit son quartier quelle que
soit sa commune
quel que soit son milieu social doit
pouvoir accéder à la culture parce que
c'est la clé pour réussir en flic ou sa
vie professionnelle et où sa vie d'homme
je crois que c'est notre mission de
transmission qui se joue ici et le fait
que nous puissions dédié ce jour de
fermeture du château de versailles à
tous les scolaires est une magnifique
idée et qu'il a permis d'intensifier un
programme qui existait déjà
cerise sur le gâteau la visite du
capitaine de l'équipe de football du
paris saint germain
la fondation les enfants d'abord du club
et par haine de l'événement quand je
suis arrivée là les enfants commençaient
à crier et tu vois qu'ils dont le visage
est déjà quand ils ont peut-être
qu'elles sont contents de me voir et
pour moi ça me touche beaucoup ça une
journée riche en souvenirs il est d'ores
et déjà prévu qu'elle soit reconduite en
2020 et 2021
[Applaudissements]